we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 David P now I'm going to
do something potentially against my
better judgment
I am going to play a voicemail from this
uh very insistent troll Troy York
now some of you might say that rings a
bell Troy York where do I know that name
Troy York has been calling into the show
and leaving voicemails for years and
years and years and months ago maybe
even longer I just stopped playing his
voicemails because they got so boring
and pedantic and pointless you didn't
like them I didn't like them they didn't
bring anything interesting to the table
recently people have been saying
whatever happened to Troy York well what
happened to Troy York is that he still
leaves two to three voicemails a day
haven't played his voicemail for months
maybe longer but he is insistently
leaving voicemail after voicemail half
of them you can barely hear what he says
his connection is a disaster the
background noise isn't is just
infuriating but I want to play one
voicemail just to show you this is
really what happens when your brain is
completely scrambled on right-wing
talking points and confusion and you're
in a daze where you completely lack any
ability to think critically or for
yourself about anything and as often as
the case Troy York uses up the full
three minute Max on our voicemail line
let's just see how far we can get
through this but understand this is your
brain on idiocy
uh David Patton
um more lies of the corrupt mainstream
media through their polling
um continue to meddle and rock into the
Pennsylvania
um
senate election and continue lies and
abuse
of polling is something that
um there needs to be rounding with these
polls mean absolutely nothing
and are meant to manipulate the votes
they always favor the Democrats well
right now John fetterman is up four in
polling in Pennsylvania and Ron DeSantis
is up five in polling in Florida
so if we can't believe any of the
polling then certainly on Election Day
both of the results in those races
should differ from the polling we'll be
able to test that in just a few weeks
they are partisan in nature they're
untrustworthy
they are deceiving and they should be
declared illegal um anyone with a brain
that's a really conservative light touch
right make polling illegal
would ignore these polls but naturally
you are like the Scarecrow from the land
of Oz you do not have a brain that
functions properly your brain Mr David
peckman is a butter
it's but it's not mayonnaise it's butter
listen
um I mean polls are generally speaking
pretty accurate you know you go back to
2020 the polling going in had Biden like
plus five
and Biden ended up winning by 7.2
um it's really pretty close in 2016 uh
let me see if I can uh 2016 Trump
Hillary I'll get the exact numbers for
us in 2016 the polling had Hillary up
three and Hillary won the popular vote
by two now of course we have this crazy
system called an electoral college and
it led to Trump winning the electoral
vote but the popular vote polls said
Hillary plus three Hillary won by two
the polling is generally speaking pretty
accurate Jordan you are so deranged with
trunk syndrome you are so delusional
with your Progressive radical extremism
yeah
um you can't even call off these polls
for the horse manure that they are
um Dr Amendment Oz is by far a healthier
stronger
more more competent
um
um person I can't speak to the
comparison between Oz and fetterman on
physical health
but Oz is in way over his head
betterments of really brilliant guy
Harvard lieutenant governor Etc
Oz doesn't know up from down and left
from right more competent
believer than John fetterman who is a
disgrace he is a scum he looks like the
average homeless guy he can't dress he
can't talk he has no ability to live a
healthy lifestyle he doesn't care
that the man is
morbidly obese unhealthy I actually
don't think fetterman's morbidly obese
anyway so that's Troy York that'll be
the one voicemail for the year he'll
keep calling in you know two to three
times a day but for those of you have
been wondering it's still the same
dribble we have a great bonus show for
you today Jenny Thomas the wife of
Supreme Court Justice Clarence Thomas
will be speaking with the house January
6th panel when and under what terms we
will discuss the woman who falsely
accused the black bird watcher remember
that wacky story and then got fired she
sued her ex-employer and has lost the
lawsuit we will talk about it many are
calling it sweet Justice I'm not calling
it that but many people are and the
World Cup captains want to wear rainbow
armbands in Qatar I have to tell you
the rainbow armbands are fine
but the stadiums were built by
essentially slave labor so this is one
of those things where yeah fine but
we're kind of missing the forest for the
trees we're going to talk about all of
those stories and more when producer Pat
joins me on today's bonus show you can
get instant access to the bonus show by
signing up at joinpakman.com and
remember we have launched the new
YouTube channel Pacman Finance
youtube.com pacmanfinance subscribe free
the clips are going up daily we'll see
you then